Transcription: Jade Le Foll
Relecteur: eric vautier
À chaque instant de votre vie,
vous prenez des décisions.
Vous vous levez le matin,
vous prenez une décision.
Vous entrez dans la douche,
c'est une décision.
Vous prenez votre voiture,
des centaines de décisions d'affilée
pour vous frayer un chemin
dans la circulation.
Ces décisions vous paraissent anodines
mais elles ont toutes un impact sur vous,
elles ont un impact
sur ce qui vous entoure,
elles ont un impact immédiat,
un impact différé,
un impact proche, un impact lointain,
elles ont même
des conséquences inattendues.
Donc c'est une énorme responsabilité.
Chaque instant de votre vie,
la décision que vous allez prendre
va modifier légèrement le monde
qui vous entoure
et même celui qui est
beaucoup plus lointain.
Cette responsabilité, parfois,
certains aimeraient bien ne pas l'assumer.
On aimerait bien ne pas être
responsable de nos décisions.
Cependant il est impossible de se défiler.
Nous sommes responsables
de toutes nos décisions.
Et toutes nos décisions
changent notre monde à chaque instant.
Et en changeant notre monde,
elles changent le monde.
Je vous parle de décisions parce que
je suis pilote professionnel.
J'ai été pilote de chasse pendant 35 ans.
J'ai effectué plus de 4 000 heures de vol
sur des avions rapides, performants,
des concentrés de technologie.
On pense généralement que
le métier de pilote de chasse
est de piloter ces avions.
En fait, le métier de pilote de chasse,
c'est bien plus que ça.
C'est d'effectuer avec la plus haute
fréquence possible
un cycle d'analyse de l'information,
d'élaboration d'une conscience
de la situation et de prise de décision
qui doivent être justes et fiables
parce que les décisions que l'on prend
dans un avion de combat sont celles qui,
d'abord, vous sauveront la vie,
deuxièmement, vous permettront
de ramener l'avion à la base
et vous permettront d'effectuer la mission
que l'on vous a confiée.
4 000 heures de vol,
200 missions de guerre,
ce sont des centaines de milliers
de décisions que j'ai prises
et j'ai fini par me demander à la fin
de ma carrière ce qui a fait que
je puisse être là devant vous
pour m'exprimer.
Parce que si je suis là, c'est que
ces décisions étaient plutôt pertinentes,
plutôt fiables, plutôt sûres,
sinon je ne serais pas là.
Et je me suis posé cette question,
je l'ai retournée dans tous les sens
et finalement, j'ai eu une seule réponse
qui m'est apparue,
c'est que ces décisions sont sûres,
fiables, pertinentes
grâce au discernement.
Le discernement, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
On peut le définir comme la faculté
de voir les choses dans leur réalité,
la faculté d'avoir une vision claire,
de prendre des décisions avec bon sens,
de voir la réalité des choses.
Mais tout ça ne nous aide pas
à augmenter notre discernement.
Ce que je voudrais vous faire comprendre
du discernement -
c'est une définition
de pilote évidemment -
c'est plutôt la capacité
de prendre de la hauteur
face à nos influences
extérieures ou intérieures -
et vous verrez qu'il y en a beaucoup,
d'influences intérieures -
pour prendre des décisions sûres
et fiables pour être aligné avec soi-même.
Ce que je vous propose, c'est tout d'abord
de comprendre quelles sont ces influences
qui nous empêchent
d'avoir une vision claire des choses
et d'être aligné avec nous-même.
Je ne vais pas faire une liste exhaustive
mais je vais vous parler
des principaux obstacles au discernement.
Le premier obstacle, le premier ennemi
du discernement, c'est l'ego.
L'ego est indispensable
à la construction de soi, évidemment.
C'est nous, c'est ce que nous sommes.
Cependant, on peut avoir un passif,
on peut avoir des souffrances
qui font que notre ego est surdimensionné,
qu'il prend le pas sur notre « nous »
et qu'il nous amène à faire des choses
que nous ne voudrions pas faire
par désir de paraître,
par désir d'estime de soi, etc.
Ça, c'est un ennemi dont il faut
se méfier grandement.
Dans le cockpit d'un avion de chasse,
nulle place pour l'ego.
L'ego tue.
Le deuxième ennemi du discernement,
c'est la paresse.
La paresse, c'est l'ennemi insidieux,
c'est ce qui vous empêche d'avancer,
c'est ce qui vous empêche
de vous poser des questions,
de dépasser vos limites,
c'est ce qui vous empêche
d'apprendre encore et encore.
La paresse est un ennemi insidieux
du discernement
parce qu'il vous assoit dans le confort
de la connaissance permanente.
Troisième problème qui s'oppose
au discernement,
troisième obstacle
au discernement : la peur.
Je ne parle pas de la peur instinctive,
de la peur qui vous soustrait à la menace,
de la peur qui vous permet
d'obtenir des ressources
que vous ne connaissiez pas
pour vous échapper,
pour vous soustraire à la mort.
Je parle de la peur qui vous tétanise,
la peur du lapin
dans les phares de voiture.
Celle qui vous empêche d'avancer,
celle qui vous empêche d'agir,
la peur qui est irréelle, en fait.
C'est une projection de vous-même dans
le futur, dans un futur qui n'existe pas,
et qui vous empêche
de prendre conscience du présent.
Il faut être conscient de cette peur
et s'en écarter.
Un quatrième obstacle :
les biais cognitifs.
Nous sommes tous élevés,
nous avons tous grandi dans une famille,
une culture, une religion pour certains,
une société qui a imprimé
dans notre cerveau des modes de pensée,
des modes de vie et notre cerveau
est plutôt fainéant, plutôt paresseux.
Il a tendance, il a une forte tendance à
confirmer ce qu'il sait déjà par paresse.
Donc il est très important
d'être conscient de nos biais cognitifs
pour pouvoir conserver
une vision objective du monde.
En tout cas, si elle n'est pas objective,
une vision qui est proche
de la subjectivité honnête.
C'est-à-dire, de savoir qu'on ne peut pas
avoir un regard complètement objectif
mais en tout cas de connaître les biais
qui nous transforment le monde.
Et puis, le dernier obstacle
au discernement,
c'est l'excès de confiance.
Bien sûr, la confiance en soi est
essentielle pour prendre des décisions.
Personne ne peut prendre une décision
s'il n'a pas confiance en lui.
Cependant, si cette confiance
est trop grande,
elle va nous faire dépasser nos limites
sans prudence, sans intelligence,
elle va nous empêcher
de connaître nos limites
et elle va nous mettre en danger,
et elle ne va pas nous permettre
d'avoir une vision claire et nette
du monde.
Donc voilà cinq gros obstacles
au discernement :
l'ego, la paresse, la peur,
les biais cognitifs
et l'excès de confiance,
la surestime de soi.
Je vais vous parler maintenant
de quelque chose qui va pouvoir vous aider
à mieux discerner et quelque chose
qu'on n'écoute pas assez souvent :
notre intuition.
Einstein disait que rien n'était valable
que l'intuition.
Évidemment, il avait une définition
de l'intuition un petit peu scientifique,
il pensait que c'était la somme de
nos expériences intellectuelles passées
qui nous permettaient
d'anticiper sur le futur.
Mais pour lui, rien d'autre
n'était valable que l'intuition.
L'intuition, en sciences,
c'est celle qui permet d'avancer,
c'est celle qui a permis à Galilée
d'imaginer que la Terre était ronde,
celle qui a permis à Newton
d'envisager la gravité,
celle qui a permis à Einstein
de penser à la relativité,
celle qui a permis à Steve Jobs
d'inventer l'iPhone,
et Dieu sait s'il a changé le monde.
On en a tous dans nos poches maintenant.
L'intuition, c'est vraiment
ce qui permet d'avancer.
On ne l'écoute pas assez.
C'est un ami, c'est une alliée
du discernement.
Donc pour changer le monde,
pour changer votre monde,
prenez conscience de ces obstacles
et augmentez votre discernement.
Pour illustrer ce propos,
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur l'Histoire.
Trois exemples rapides
qui vont vous faire comprendre
qu'avec du discernement,
le monde aurait un autre visage.
Premier exemple, Napoléon.
En 1807, Napoléon signe avec le tsar
de Russie les accords de Tilsit
et il considère le tsar comme son frère,
égal à égal.
Deux egos surdimensionnés
qui se considèrent comme des alliés.
Napoléon ira même jusqu'à demander la main
de la sœur du tsar, qui lui sera refusée.
Cet affront sera très mal vécu
par Napoléon
et le tsar va lui demander de ne pas
rétablir la Pologne dans ses droits.
Napoléon va refuser puisqu'il était vexé
de ne pas avoir la main de sa sœur
et s'ensuit une guerre d'ego monstrueuse
qui va dégénérer
et qui va donner la campagne de Russie,
la catastrophe de la retraite de Russie,
plus de 410 000 soldats napoléoniens
vont mourir de faim, de froid
et dans les combats,
et finalement, la fin
du règne de Napoléon.
Un deuxième exemple
un peu plus proche de nous :
la montée des fascismes en 1929.
Après la Première Guerre mondiale,
traité de Versailles,
signature de la paix.
Le traité de Versailles
était un traité égotiste
qui voulait vraiment mettre les perdants
dans la misère et les ruiner.
Sun Tzu, pour ceux qui l'ont lu,
sait très bien que ce n'est pas la façon
d'obtenir la paix.
Pour obtenir la paix,
il faut soigner son adversaire,
il faut lui permettre de se relever
et il faut lui permettre
de perdre dans la dignité
sinon, pas de paix possible.
Le traité de Versailles
a fait tout l'inverse.
Les peuples ont été maltraités
et une certaine rancœur s'est installée.
Puis la crise économique est arrivée.
Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Certains pouvoirs ont profité de la peur
qui commençait à naître chez les peuples
pour attiser la haine entre les peuples.
On leur a fait peur de perdre,
on leur a fait peur de manquer,
on leur a fait peur des autres,
on a attisé cette peur
pour que la haine naisse,
et tous ces peuples qui avaient dit
en 1918 :
« C'est la der des ders,
plus jamais on ne recommencera »,
aveuglés par leur peur,
ont recommencé à se massacrer.
Un troisième exemple positif, cette fois :
rappelez-vous en 1940,
la puissance allemande,
en trois jours, défait la France.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Eh bien, par intuition,
de Gaulle qui était un militaire
dans le cœur et dans l'âme,
prend la décision de partir en Angleterre.
Et je pense, je vous assure que pour lui,
c'était une décision terrible
parce que c'était un vrai soldat
et c'était une façon de s'en aller,
de baisser les bras, de poser les armes
mais il a eu cette intuition
que rien n'était possible sans partir.
Et de l'autre côté de la Manche,
Churchill, lui, a eu l'intuition de ne pas
signer la paix avec les Allemands
parce que tout le poussait
à signer cette paix.
La puissance allemande,
la faiblesse des défenses
de la Grande-Bretagne à cette époque,
et le Parlement anglais
qui le poussait à signer la paix.
Mais Churchill a suivi son intuition.
Il n'a pas signé cette paix,
il a engagé le combat avec l'Allemagne.
Et imaginez le monde d'aujourd'hui
si de Gaulle et Churchill
n'avaient pas suivi leur intuition.
Je voulais illustrer comment
avec plus de discernement,
comment en évacuant vos peurs,
comment en vous méfiant de votre ego,
comment en n'étant pas paresseux,
en travaillant, en avançant,
comment en étant conscient
de vos biais cognitifs, de votre culture
et en les prenant en compte
dans votre vision du monde,
comment en étant actif, toujours,
vous pourrez changer votre monde
et en changeant votre monde,
je vous le garantis,
vous changerez le monde.
Merci de votre attention.